je suis évidemment contre pour tout un
tas de raisons mais et pour deux raisons
pour deux raisons essentielles
la première c'est que je suis éleveur
producteur de viande bovine dans le
département de la loire
j'ai l'intimé conviction de produire des
biens alimentaires d'une qualité
certaine tant sur le point de vue
nutritif que sur le point de vue
sanitaire
mais je serai j'habite à 80 km de lyon
et je serai très fier et très heureux
que les enfants les gueugnonnais mange
deux mange de la viande notre produit de
charmants d'exploitation sont sanitaires
et économiques et l'autre l'autre raison
l'autre l'autre raison est enfin un juge
juste avait terminé sur ma position a
remis aux explications quand même c'est
plus qu'il mange de la viande plutôt que
de manger des galettes de touffou fait
avec du soja produit à l'autre bout du
monde ou du poisson venant de norvège
d'indonésie ou de je ne sais où
et ça comme vous l'avez dit dans dans
votre introduction tout à l'heure dans
la ville de paul bocuse dans la ville de
l'adn de la mère brazier et dans la
ville des frères barbet deuxième élément
pourquoi je suis content c'est que la
décision de monsieur doucet elle est
d'une hypocrisie la plus totale et la
plus scandaleuse explique henno il a
pris cette décision sous couvert de la
preuve de la couverture sanitaire comme
s'était expliquée par par mon confrère
éleveurs tout ça tout ça c'est une île
est une ineptie la plus grande
cette décision c'est la même chose c'est
que l'art est il cette décision c'est
d'abord la mise en ce sens son idéologie
politique et si ça posait un problème à
la ville de lyon pourquoi ça ne poserait
pas dans d'autres villes moi dans mon
département la ville de feurs où de
roanne par exemple pour ne citer
qu'elles elles sont contraints ou aller
à l'algérie à une crise sanitaire
elles ont elles font face elle sert de
la l1 continue de servir de la viande
donc là on est bien dans l'idéologie
politique d'amer écologistes de
l'assouvir sas à son idéologie est ce
que vous allez
est ce que vous allez entreprendre des
actions pour vous opposer à l'argent de
mesure où on va on entreprit déjà des
actions et en a saisi la justice parce
que au-delà de tout ce que je veux dire
monsieur le maire de lyon est hors la
loi puisque le puisque les repas dans
les cantines c'est quelque chose qui est
sérieux ça c'est pas françois qui
arrivent et qui les fait c'est pas c'est
que c'est quelque chose qui est fait par
des nutritionnistes qui encadraient et
qui encadrés par la loi est la loi qui
date de 2000 ans et qui était qui était
approfondie et mise en place par un
décret qui date de 2011 oblige la
restauration la restauration scolaire à
une alternance de plats dans lesquels on
doit retrouver tout un tas de tout un
tas de produits dont la viande
donc de fait j'aimerais relever du bon
sens ça relève du bon sens et on
regrette monsieur doucet par rapport à
ce sujet très précis et hors la loi on a
saisi le préfet du rhône pour remédier
maintenant s'il fabre la cilicie les
maires commencent à mettre à être hors
la loi et faire ce qu'ils veulent en
fait on est dans la démagogie la plus
totale et et pour nous tous en tout cas
et pour les éleveurs que je représente
et dont je suis le porte parole de ce
soir c'est quand même un peu insultant
d'être maire d'une ville entourée de
territoires qui sont entretenues par les
éleveurs ont valorisé par les éleveurs
et dire que finalement les produits que
vous faites bien dans vos exportations
sur le
ministre de l'agriculture tout à fait de
normandie a également saisi la face à
agathe sur la question de la
restauration scolaire en particulier la
loi française va même plus loin parce
qu'il existe depuis sa mise en place du
1er novembre 2019 la loi agriculture et
alimentation qui est la loi et galim on
en france et qui invite tous les
établissements scolaires à inclure un
menu végétarien donc là pour le coup
sans viande sans poisson dans leur
semaine à l'école ou bien en menu
alternatif donc qui impose ce choix aux
enfants ou un jour végétarien dans la
semaine pour que les enfants sont les
sensibiliser à une autre façon de
consommer et sensibiliser nos enfants à
manger moins de viande à consommer
autrement à consommer plus vert qu'on se
le mieux à consommer mieux exactement
bien sûr qu'il faut aller dans ce
sens-là
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on ait beaucoup
sur ce plateau être plutôt partagés
parce qu'il ya quand même audiard et 2
indécis
parce qu'il ya un gouffre eric entre
cette loi qui existe qui est choquant ce
nécessaire d'un jour végétarien par
semaine à la proposition de ce doux
c'est qu'il va mettre en place pour les
sept semaines à venir et qui exclut
complètement la viande du lundi au
vendredi dans une hypocrisie complète
qui est d'après ce que j'ai lu toutes
ses interviews je me suis tapé ses
boucles et gérard louvin ce qu'il a
utilisé une science du buzz et de la
polémique qui est innée et c'est pour ça
que je remplisse le second reproche
exactement les conduire en tournée il
des îles
il invoque une praticité c'est beaucoup
plus pratique la viande oeufs semble
donc c'est beaucoup plus pratique pour
l'instant de chine parce que je suis
contre monsieur douce et mais je suis
pour un jour végétarien dans la salle